Laur is lovely to have you here today of
course we know you best for your role in
your first big TV show gay
what was it like being the new girl on
the block there it was amazing
it really was hey it didn't seem like I
was no one seemed to be apprehensive or
anything everyone was really really
lovely and I think there was quite a few
new ones that season so we all just yeah
we all just blundered quite fast
fantastic now what do you enjoy most
about playing as an actress I actually
love the mask even though everyone
always goes it's hard being an actor and
wearing a mask and the truth says no
because I gets you into character really
easily and be she'sshe's very enigmatic
very mysterious took me a while to
figure her helping myself for myself and
I still haven't fully I'm curious to see
where they're taking her and then you
have read some of the books as well has
that helped you as well enigma
absolutely it really hasn't I have a lot
of friends who were fans of the show
before so they've told me you come back
in fact 5x6 and you say she's mysterious
character an enigma I mean I'm not quite
sure exactly what's going on with her in
the show are we why do I mean is it is
you're kind of trying to think your way
around her as an actress why do you
think she was helping Danny in the the
last time we saw us we don't really know
we don't really I don't really know if
she is helping or not mm-hmm that's
always the question because the
directions she sensed any unnecessary
are not necessarily off I'm not
necessarily good for her way so I think
more will be revealed I mean there's an
actress how do you find that then about
getting into the character when it is so
kind of up and out they're not quite
sure what's going on I think as an actor
you have to make a decision you have to
make a decision whether she is good evil
in between who she is where she comes
from what her backstory is I kind of
have made those decisions for me and I
hope I do her justice with the way I'm
taking her and of course at the end of
the day the lines are written and
they're written fabulously
and there is enough in the lines and
would've for me to know what I have to
do with her I would put it that way
probably and it's not hard she's such a
good character now we can see from what
she was that she has links with
Melisandre absolutely yeah so
interesting to see how that develops I
mean what she's another one of my one of
my favorite actresses as well yeah I'm a
really big fan of Karis one out happen
for a long time she's in a film called
black book which have you seen it which
I love and when I actually read the
casting director and initially wound up
before I got the job and it says she's
in the family and that son needs to be
somewhat similar to Karis why now and I
thought oh my god no pressure just my
favorite actors list in but I have to
meet her oh yeah because it's such a big
car necessarily overlapping when your
shoes no I mean we'll all meet yeah
we'll all meet conventions and stuff and
and it feels like we follow each other I
know I know what you did on Saturday but
I don't know favorite characters in Game
of Thrones who's who really stands out
for you I love Cersei I love her hmm
it's a dream role she's so good in it
yeah of course I love the character
sunsets you know she's she's feisty
she's great and I I would say and
Daenerys simply because I think Amelia's
fantastic I'm wondering what your
favorite scenes and your favorite
episodes have been well as always but
memorable one you too to a naked very
good eye I did enjoy that I mean I kind
of knew versus before because there was
also one of my audition scenes um and
then when you have the naked man in
front of you and that was nice that was
a really great scene I actually really
enjoyed it as if it's just it's just
very magical really
I remember it was like right in the
desert this thing that they built and
actually to be fair were really lucky
all the scenes were quite amazing and I
obviously knew who England was and so I
met him just the day before we started
shooting had a rehearsal and he was so
cool and so nice so kind so don't get
too starstruck and then I I really
enjoyed our scene actually and the party
scene was great too yeah awesome yeah it
was really nice there's a lot of extras
very it's really big production and we
were on this island just off Dubrovnik
it was quite magical and was it like
shooting in Croatia well under poverty
look I could have stayed honestly I
could have stayed forever I really loved
it
I it's a really really beautiful city
very good food lovely people and
everyone is so excited Game of Thrones
being shot there so the whole city has a
bit of a game of Thrones vibe and at
night y'all go to restaurants together
and surreal it's really hard to come
back from it and kind of come back to
normal life in London because it's it's
it's a really wonderful bubble and a
really wonderful world that they created
what's it like behind the scenes on Game
of Thrones
what would fans who watch the show and
live watching it and live the books as
well fine surprising about life behind
the scenes how great friends everyone is
you might kill each other on the show
but then we all go out and have a glass
of wine and eat and no matter what
happens it's it doesn't translate into
the evening
I find anyway I mean I remember when um
when Roxanne strangled I'm right and
that evening we all had dinner and then
we hung out in the room eating chocolate
so it's you know I think that's what's
really beautiful because we're all more
or less the same age I mean you have you
have the kids obviously as well but
they're in bed by that time but more and
more or less they made and some of us
have known each other from London and so
it's really a fun group of people so how
do you think you'd fire inque's wells
in that brutal world not so great
I'm me Lera I'm a pacifist peaceful
mellow person I think I think I'd be
really freaky to hell I'm not
I probably try to find a diplomatic
solution and be killed for it to be
honest that's so yeah not so grand I
think I wouldn't know I mean I stand for
what I believe in
I'm not an aggressive I mean you need
some serious interesting qualities to
survive I think and go with rosy you had
to say like you need this this and this
to keep alive you know those things
where do you think a good weapon yes
persistence a good brain a strategic
frame yeah strategic mind which I don't
have
by any means I'm much more in the artist
side a good map would be helpful yeah
exactly
yeah I think you have to be very sharp I
think that's part of why the show is so
good as well because it's a bit like
real life isn't it you have to survive
you have to be a fighter and you have to
be smart about your choices and you have
to be straight smart I mean if you say
at the end of the day once George RR
Martin's written those final books and
we've seen them on this new screen who
do you think is gonna come out on top is
it gonna be the Starks or the line that
says all the Targaryen who do you like
to see on the Iron Throne
what does they start but then things do
change and you do find yourself being
more involved in another characters
storyline or you think yeah I liked you
Europe not a word I can say here I think
things like the new Jamie Lannister as
well because perceptions of him Oh
change
I don't like it completely yeah and we
just don't really know sometimes which
team they play for do exactly what was
it like somebody in the show watching
the red wedding what was your reaction
pretty much the same as everyone else I
was absolutely shocked I didn't I just
didn't expect it to be that I mean I
knew it was going to be brutal but then
you watch it and it's just a lot more
brutal than you expect if you could
bring anybody back who we've lost a farm
we've lost lots of people and go with
ruins haven't we over the three seasons
huger bring back personal favorites I
have to say amorita because she's a
really good friend of mine though she's
a bit dead now
she plays area I mean if we had to lose
quite obviously don't want to how would
you like to go out I would like someone
to rip the Moscow Oh stab me in my face
he would be like I haven't given anyone
any ideas now either if we think of
ahead to season four sin yes yeah what
are you looking forward to about season
four I really look forward to Daenerys
journey I really want to know where
she's going what's happening now where
where she will end up because I think it
was kind of left at season 3 after that
you just just like season two even as
well we just didn't know and so many I
think more review revealed so I'm really
looking forward to seeing where where
the journey takes her and what
challenges come up what he meant for you
to be part of Gareth brains
everything has just changed everything
and it's really changed my life my
career and I kind of a come from the
theatre so I wasn't quite used to that
kind of exposure and it's a dream
everyone it's a dream for most actors I
think to be on such a fantastic show I'm
I feel I feel really fortunate we were
really honest it's not it's not
something that I I can't
I could really I mean it's something you
hope for as an actor you always hope to
get on a really really good TV show and
then when it happens you're very
grateful what do you like to say to the
fans
show you who are watching this video
Alan they're the best fans I had no I go
to the conventions too I just actually
came back from one and just the nicest
people and that's why the show is doing
as well as it does because fans are so
involved in it and they care about it so
much
really the best day I I've sat I signed
a guitar this weekend
I signed t-shirts I find this incredible
he hopefully he's watching this he
brought this incredible of a piece of
silk fabric where he had to narrow his
paint it on and I got to sign that I how
cool yeah they're really they're really
creative and they make beautiful costume
it's a fantasy world and it's really
nice to be part of well our it's been
lovely very lovely speaking to you thank
you
you